june is alzheimer's and brain awareness
month advocates are encouraging people
to make brain health a priority this
month and every month
bianca holman is live with more bianca
lots of caregivers out there
know how hard this disease is because
they live it with them
every single day don't they
yeah they sure do sheri and it's
caregivers who bring their loved ones to
places like this
the lou rouveaux center for brain health
here in las vegas
and you know more than 11 million
americans are unpaid caretakers for
those living with alzheimer's or
dementia
the disease it takes a toll on the
entire family
as we transition back to normal life the
alzheimer's association wants people to
think about their brain health
we have a very active association here
in our area that offers supports
for loved ones advocates recommend don't
argue with the person
try to make time for yourself which can
be difficult of course and ensure your
health is in good condition
and get the family member a medical id
bracelet
when the disease is mild if there's
something
that the patient always wanted to do
always wanted to go to australia
i would recommend going when it's mild
because you're not going to be able to
unfortunately go
when it's severe and also you know
you can continue to do things as best
you can that they like doing
some factors affecting brain health
cannot be changed but there are
lifestyle changes that if incorporated
early in life can make somewhat of a
difference
you can see them listed here on your
screen just healthy living
regular exercise healthy eating getting
enough sleep
mental stimulation like learning
something new managing your stress
and of course staying socially engaged
and again again lots of information here
in the valley and
many people sharing awareness on social
media and a lot of people
wearing the color purple to help bring
attention to this and like you said
sherry
wearing bringing attention to this not
just this month but throughout the
entire year
reporting live bianca holman 8 news now
thanks bianca the longest day coming up
for
it's a big fundraiser for the
alzheimer's association later later this
month
appreciate you bringing awareness to it
this
this morning bianca thanks so much